пряме включення з Шевченківського суду
тут у справі шангвінського відбувається
прокурорсько-судівський беспредел ви
собі уявіть мит на 15:40 збираємося сюди
в суд на оскарження підозри адвокати про
це завчасно подали клопотання було
призначене засідання воно було на сайті
І от ми приїжджаємо сюди Ми всі бачимо
Романа тут немає і прийшов суддя який
заявляє що виявляється в 12-й годині
було якесь призначене засідання без
повідомлення на сайті без жодної
інформації без повідомлення адвокатів
тобто увага це порушення всі конвенції з
прав людини що роману червінському було
його позбавлено було право взагалі з
комунікувати з адвокатами і отримувати
належний захист роману вже чотири місяці
тримають під вартою без права застави на
відміну від Коломойського та іншої
нечисті його тримають під вартою без
права бачитися зі своїми рідними з
дружиною з сестрою мамою дітьми